Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to 'Dark Echo'
Now this game is entirely based on echolocation
and if you can see it from the title those aren't just worms squiggling all around
that's kinda the style of the game
you are... -bahk
It's hard to describe, I'll let the game speak for itself because I'm not an expert anyway, so,
*sounds of footsteps along with shoe images*
You- are simply waking around and using that to navigate the hallways that you're in
So, if I'm walking-
It's kinda like that game- I can't remember what the game that I played, uh, a few months ago was,
but it, it's kind of a similar thing, you use sound,
*door unlocks and opens with a creak*
as a way to visualize the environment around you.
Whereas, that one was 3D.
This one is top-down.
And supposedly, and I'm not 100% percent on this, but supposedly there's some horror elements to it.
*loud clacking/stomping noise that echoes through the room* Oh. Oh, god. I don't wanna stomp my feet like that.
*stomping continues*
Oh. Oh, it's beautiful.
*footsteps start up again* Oh, that is- that literally is beautiful the way it all bounces around like that.
Oh, that's so cool!
Ah, goddamit, I'm saying it again.
I'm doing that thing where I say how cool it is.
*low voice* And it's cool in varying amounts.
Yeah, gotta build it up. *stomps* BWUAAH!
Maybe a little bit-  *stomps* Bing!
Okay. Alrighty then.
Ah, that's so bizarre, the way they tendril off *stomps* into the darkness.
*room shakes, sounds of crumbling*
Woah- Woahh!
Heeyyyy! Is that a cave in over there or sumthin? *stomps* Boink!
Muhh, am I gonna have to be quiet eventually? Probably.
*laughs* That's not my style.
But the other game, it tapped into the microphone, which was like a TOTALLY different experience, because it made like a different level of immersion,
and especially made it difficult for Let's Players because we had to talk!
And apparently we could not. *door unlocks and creaks open*
Okayyy, we made it out of that one. Bizarrely enough.
De- DEatH??! I thought it was gonna be y'know hide or something! It was like Escape, Death...
Big jump *stomps* between the two.
Alrighty then. How is death going to approach? Uhhhahh!
*realization* OhhhHHhh. *stomps* AaahhHHHhh.
Okay. So that would be death if I went down there.
I just have to be mindful of the places of death. Woah.
*sounds of swarming flies*
Euuuhhh! What is that?
What is that?! I don't like the sound of that.
I don't like the sound of anything here. *stomps* Ooooh.
*swarming sounds amplify*
Is there a dead body there??
Woahhh. So it's not my death we were talking about. It's the death of others who were too stupid to not walk into a bunch of death. *door unlocks and opens*
Euuhhhh.
This is so cool though- "Fear"?! *sarcastically* Oh no!
Bring it on.
I'm a master of fear. *stomps* I'm a master of all my emotions.
But most of all fea- WOAHHWOAHHSWOAAHOOIIII!!!
*low roaring from red light emanating from monster*
WOAH! WOAH GOD! HOW DO I RUN?!?!
OH SHIT! AHH FUCK YOU *man screams in agony in-game as he's ripped apart* OHHohoho Godddd!
Oh the sounds of my doom echo through the hallways! *laughs* Holy shit!
*sniffs* Oh, okay.
Okay!
Let's try that again!
Let's go through this way. Uh-oh. *monster growls menacingly*
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO RUN!
*high pitched scream x2* *monster continues growling*
Okay, we're fine. Everything's fine.
EVERYBODY DON'T PANIC!
The last thing last thing we need is panicking. Oh shit.
*high pitched scream*
Oh. Oooh. Oh! If you tiptoe! *footstep sounds halt*
It'll eventually- *growling stops* Oooh. Goooood.
Yess. Yess! YESSS! Don't slay!
YAASSS! Don't slay me!
Okay! *triumphantly* YEAH!
*door opens* That's so cool! Agh goddamit! It's- it's- it's really neato!
Woowww! How- Ohh shit we're being hunted now. Okay.
*low voice* Ooooh. Let's be super stealthy about this. *stomps* KAPAH!!!
Oh no! It's- *loud ominous creak*
Uhhhhh...
*stomps* ACHOO!
Okay! Movin' along. Nothing to see here.
*scat singing* Ha-ba-eh-bee-um-ba-omh-ba-bo
*stomps* I'd been married *voice cracks as monster growls and approaches* a long time ago!
*nervous laughter* Oh, oohhhh ohhhh uhhuooh. No (x5)
Ah.
Oooh.
That would've been death.
WOAH. I'm skirting right along the edge of death.
*volume increases as he leans close to mic* But it's a good thing that I'm very smart about this and I know exactly what I'm doing at all times.
*sinister voice* So I'm never going to be worried about death.
*stomps* AHBLETHEHH!
Sorry. *monster roars* *nervous laughter* AHAHHhahahuhuhuhuhuhhh.
*high pitched* OOOhuhHUHhuuu!
Okay.
We just gotta be careful, calm, and collected about it.
*stomps*
Nice. Heheh, nice. Nice! Okay. We should be fine. Maybe. Maybe not.
Ooh? Yeaahhahahaha baby!
Ohhh yessssss. Yessss. *laughing* YEeehhehehehesssss.
Aw, this isn't nice(?) This game is on Steam and I believe it only costs like 3 or 4 dollars? But,
I don't know how long the game is. You never really know with these indie games but,
this is innovative, it's new, it's interesting,
*stomps* It's fascinating. Woah.
What is that?
*suspiciously* What is that?!
What is that?!
Should I touch it? Wooh! *unlocking noise, then stones shift* Uhhh.
Okayyy. It was a switch. It was like a button.
Ooohhh.
*water drips*
Woah!
*stomps* ACHOO! Sorry. Water droplets make me sneeze.
Alrighty then. Oh! Is that good? Is that exit?
Oooh, that's exit but it seems to be blocked off. So there's gotta be,
*inhales* someway to open that up. Maybe.
Maybe someway around it, I'm not 100% sure. *stomps* Ok- ooh. Death.
Nice. *switch unlocks* Okay, got that. Alright. So if we go- Yeaahh. Oooh!
What the hell is with all the sound being trapped in there?
That is nice though. That is super cool.
That is- Ah fuck it! It's so cool! Oh, look at that it's pretty!
That's another thing about it. Like it's one thing to have- WOAH. "Stranger"?
Someone on my side, maybe? Or someone that I should be worried about?
Uh-oh.
*water drips in distance* Oh boy.
Okay. *switch unlocks*
One.
*sing song* A- twohooohooo!
*switch unlocks* *water drips*
*stomps* Uh-huhhh.
*footsteps splash in shallow water* Nothing in there.
But there's bound to be something on the south side.
Weird water droplets and I have a funny feeling there's gonna be someone around. *footsteps lessen*
*flies swarm faintly* That's really cool. They also make the rooms sound different to give you like,
the idea is that each room is actually a room in like,
*switch unlocks* a real environment. Well, not a real environment. But an environment in this game,
and each one has it's own unique sound. *switch unlocks* To give you the idea of like, the materials used.
Well, this is a predicament.
*flies swarm* I don't seem to have a way around here. Ah, there we go.
SUPER secret, *switch unlocks* southwestern entrance.
Bink. *stomps* *another set of footsteps starts up in front of him, hurrying quickly away* Oh.
YEAH YOU BETTER RUN! *door slams ahead* I'M TERRIFYING!
I'M SUPERRR SCARY! *door unlocks*
How am I to know that the enemies are actually "enemies" and they actually want to kill me?
Besides the fact that they kill me!
"Deception". OHHhhhh. So is this guy gonna try to mess with me?
Is that how this is gonna go? Well, I am 'unmesswithable'.
*stomps* Uh-huh.
*switch unlocks* *monster growls* Oh. Noooo! AHHHH!
Oh God!
Oh. Okay!
*laughs* Well that ain't good.
Maybe the growling should be an indication that *switch unlocks* they're probably not good for me.
*another monster growls* OHOHOHO! WOAAHHHhh. Hey, hang on there.
Alright. Good thing they're slow. Holy shit.
I think that was a way down to the south there but I'm not sure, it was a little bizarre.
*switch unlocks* Eeh. Eehh. *footsteps cease* You'll never find me, I'm super stealthy.
I'm super stealthy. Yeah, you go the wrong way. IDIOT. *footsteps start up again*
Heheheh. Okay. What else we got?
Eeh. *switch unlocks* Wooo. Ahh.
Oh. *door unlocks & opens creakily* Ohoho! Yeah! Okay.
Not bad at all. The only thing that I worry about is,
there can only be so much,
to this game, considering it's the same concept. They need to innovate with new features.
*inhales* Uh, pretty soon, or else it's just gonna be the same thing repeated over and over again in a different layout.
Which is finEEEEEE-UUHH!
*multiple monsters growl threateningly* Wooh.
Wooh-wooh. Eeuh. Why are they trapped in boxes?
*switch unlocks* Oh shit. I'm about to unleash them aren't I?
Eeuuh.
Yepp, this is labyrinthian.
Eeuahh.
*spiraling light makes high pitched whines* Eeh!
SORRY
Did that thing just die?! *stomps* Ohh that was my fault wasn't it?
Ooh shit. *switch unlocks* *monster sounds increase* Oookay...
Why are there just pockets of monsters? I don't like that.
*monster roars get increasingly louder* That's not good.
Oh, that's not good.
Ooh, that's not good either. That's instant death.
So there's gotta be something else,
*deep inhale* Oh, it's just gonna spin me in circles over and over again isn't it? Ooh, hey, how's it goin'?
*entire place shakes and rocks begin to crumble* EAUH!! Well that didn't sound good!
*monsters roar fiercely* Uh oh!
*door unlocks* Oh good!
Oh okay. That- that was a big!
That was a BIG!
That was- Oh my God. "Silence". I already know about sneaking!
I already know!
*sassy mean girls voice* I- I'm aware. I'm AWARE. I've been using this technique for awhile.
I am a very advanced gamer! And I've been playing,
for a long time! Okay? So let me, be me,
be me, *shifts to vaguely posh british accent* and you, can shut the fuck up.
Huh? How bout that?
Okay.
*door unlocks and creaks open* Well that was easy. Okay then, I already knew about that.
They were very upset for a second there.
"Creep". Okay, so who am I going to be creeping on? *water drips, flies swarm*
Ah. That's who I'm going to be creeping on.
The dead bodies and the water droplets because there's a lot of death over here and I don't like it.
I know they placed these water droplets just to be able to guide me along my way,
but I can do... this.
*stomps* ACHOO!
*monster growls in distance* Wuh-oh.
HAUAHHAHAHHAAO- I'm fine. *door unlocks*
*witchy laugh* Heeheehehheheh. Uh-oh. I think one of them just got out of the place.
It escaped.
"Subterfuge". What does that mean?
Am I going to be doing the distraction this time?
Maybe. *wind like noise blows continuously*
Uh-oh. *water drips* Well. Wow.
What is that sound?
Oh, that's so weird.
I've always said that good horror games have great audio and,
this is no exception even though obviously the entire game is based on the concept of audio?
*inhale* but not in an auditory, like, listening sense, it's-
it's a physical manifestation of what audio is, so, of course that has to be good, but also,
y'know, it compliments it with actual good sound design of the rooms. And you can tell how big the room you're in is.
And you can tell what is like made of, and all that other stuff.
*stomps* ACHOO!
Oops.
Okay, we're fine. *stomps* Hhbthhh!
OH GOD I SHOULDN'T HAVE EATEN THAT THREE BEAN SALAD! *stomps* HUHBTHHH! Oh God.
Oh, I can hold it down. *deep inhale* *blows air out with a fart* *stomps*
Aww yeah. That-that-that was a good one. That was good.
Okay, I know where I'm goin'. *door unlocks* Alrighttt.
*weird laughs* Yeahahahahahhaha. Okay, so,
You can charge up your stomps, I didn't know that. "Witness"? Who's gonna witness me?
There should be no witnesses. I'm gonna be all shiny and chrome.
*stomps* *small fart noise*
Okay. *monster growls in distance* *a second pair of footsteps starts up* Uh-Oh.
Well, that didn't sound good. *monster sounds grow ouder* EHH?!
Who's that?! Who's there?!
*monster chasing second pair of footsteps and roaring* Woah god! Oh, that's big!
Oh, that's very big!
*second set of footsteps continues, makes it to door and goes out* Oh, he made it out!
Ohhhh, that is biggg!
*monster growls menacingly* Woahhh.
Heyyyy! Hey buddy!
Heyy buddy, hey buddy, heyyyy.
*footsteps start up* Ok, I think I can walk. *monster approaches* Oh geez. OH GEEZ.
Ohh gosh, oh gossh. Eeauhhhh.
Oh, I see.
I see. I gotta be like sneaky.
I gotta wait for him to come by, and then sneak on by.
*monster growls increase*
Eeuh. Eeuhh!
It's literally the blob that ate everything.
Okay, here we go. Hehhh, ehhh- YOU'LL NEVER CATCH ME! *door unlocks*
Wow! I set off a bomb with that door! Holy shit!
Nice.
"Interlock". I don't know what that means...
Uhhh...hello.
*light clicking noises* Ohhhhh....
Ahh. *footsteps start up* OOH.
That seems dangerous. Okay.
What about- *monster growls, switch unlocks* WAHHH!
AHHHH!
Eehnnh. *evil laugh* Hehehehehheheheheh.
You can't detect me, you have NO idea.
Alright. So there's gotta be another- Oooh. Oh geez.
There's gotta be another opposite side because of course it's gonna duality system like that.
*monster roars* *footsteps cease and switch unlocks* AHHH! *descending pitch* You don't know! You have no idea, you have no idea, have no idea, I'm out baby.
I'M OUT BABY!
I don't even need to run- Oh shit. *twin monster growls* That- that's- that's the opposite of good.
*nervous laughter* Ahahah ahahha woahhoho huhahahuha huahhahHAHAAHA! *door unlocks*
*evil laugh* AHAHhahhahahaa!
Ahh. I know what I'm doing, I know what I'm doing. I'm like an expert at this game didn't you know?
"Splash"? That doesn't sound good.
My hair is weiiirddd at the moment, I apologize.
*sounds of running water* Ohhh.
*splashes into water represented by blue* OHHH.
I can't sneak in this can I? *loud sloshing through water*
Oh no, I cannot.
Okay. That's interesting.
Fascinating.
FASCINATING! Oh, it's SO cool.
There's gonna be like a- OH IT IS!
It's like an Amnesia like water monster.  *monsters growl* Ah shit!
Oh god, dude! Ah fuck! EEAAHHH!
Okay. We're fine, we're fine, we're fine. *door unlocks*
I think I'm gonna make it to level 20 and then I'll probably end the video there...
Because I don't know how many levels are in this game, but if you guys wanna try this for yourselves, this is reallllyyyy cool.
*immediate frog ribbet in blue* Oh.
Hi! How's it going? *footsteps start, frog ribbets again* Oh geez.
Lemme just- *sucks teeth* AHHHH- *stomps*
Okay. Oh shit. Welp! Shouldn't've done that!
That was a dumb idea.
But he won't be able to tell where I am until I'm already gone. *monster growls from behind*
Oh shit, he knows where I am I'm not already gone yet!
Oooh fuck.
Ohh shit.
OHHH SHIT.
Eehnnh.
*laughs* Heheheheaaheh. What a stupid idiot!
What a big dumb doofy idiot.
Hehehehheheh. Okay.
There's probably going to be another one over here somewhere.
Probably. If I had to guess.
Somewhere around here. *monster growls* WHOP!
Habadup pff pfff pfff *blows raspberries*
Okay, I'm gonna do this.
*inhales* PEHHH! *stomps*
Okay. But then they're gonna go to the origin point of the sound, cuz- yeah I figured there'd be two of them,
Then I can just sneak around 'em, and everything's gonna be A-okay.
And then I won't have to trance (prance?) through the water.
Which is the ideal. Because the water is gonna generate noise no matter what I do.
So best to go around. There we go! *door unlocks* YAYYY! Again, we did it.
What's next?
"Pull". OHHH. We're introducing new concepts here.
What am I 'sposed to pull?
Am I pulling a monster towards me? *water drips*
Aahhh?
*footsteps splashing in shallow water*
Nooope- not, oh, yeah, that way. Okay.
What do we have? *splash in shallow water*
What am I looking at? It's just a- it's just a... block. *more water drips*
*splashing through shallow water* Huh.
Alright, I'll go through the water then. *splashes into deep water*
I don't- *monster growls* OHHH SHIT!
Ohhh sHIt! *realization dawns* OOHH! AHHH! PULL! Pull the monster! Okay, I know.
I gotcha. I getcha (x6)
Whoop! And I disappeared.
How weird. I'm gone.
Just like that, I vanished into the night.
LITERALLY, like a shadow, in the night.
Okay.
So now I should be able to walk fine. *splashes into water* It doesn't matter anyway, the water was there.
Okay but that's the end of that!
Okay, so actually I'm gonna end it here, my voice is just thrashed.
Thank you everybody so much for watching! *door unlocks* This game is really cool. Like, I- I don't know if it justifies the price-
But I leave that for you to decide, so,
Thank you everybody so much for watching! And as always, I will see YOU, in the next video.
*voice cracks* Buh byeee!
BAHHHH.